now the Prime Minister Rishi sunak has
defended the actions of the metropolitan
police following criticism of the force
over the arrests of protesters during
the king's coronation officers for the
Met made 64 arrests on Saturday 46
people were bailed after being detained
on suspicion of causing a public
nuisance or breaching the peace well in
a statement this evening the Mets said
six of those bailed have been informed
they will face no further action and
they regretted that they had been unable
to take part in the protest as a result
of being arrested Sky Shaman Freeman
Powell has more
the police were aided by a new law that
was introduced only a week before the
coronation this new law means that
police now have the powers to stop and
search anyone that they believe are
setting out to cause chaos it
effectively means that the police are
now allowed to arrest people before a
protest even happens so and now it's
being confirmed that 64 people were
arrested and four people were charged
and the circumstances around these
arrests have drawn criticism too we've
heard reports of people claiming that
they were arrested simply for wearing
t-shirts or waving placards we've heard
of the incident of Graham Smith the
chair of the anti-monarchy campaign
group he claims that despite working for
months with the police ahead of the
correlation that he was arrested and
detained for around 16 hours and in a
separate incident we've heard reports of
volunteers of a women's safety campaign
group handing out rape alarms in the
early hours of Saturday morning also
facing arrest now that at incident
prompted a response by the leader of
Westminster Council who is also a labor
councilor Adam hugg he tweeted that we
know it has been a very busy and
challenging weekend for all services but
there are lessons to learn both on the
substance on which there has been
progress but not a resolution on all
matters and on how the police engage
with both the public and partners to
rebuild trust now the police will argue
that they did work with protesters to
give them a space to protest peacefully
they will also argue that they needed to
be heavy-handed when it came to arrest
given the amount of VIPs and heads of
state that were in attendance at the
coronation and this is something that
Karen Findlay who is the Met police
Commander agrees with she defended the
police saying when you take that into
consideration she believes that the
police had acted proportionately